[Music]
Brandon it's so great to be here with
you today it's a pleasure so let's start
off by talking to me about exactly what
meow does meow is a highin banking
platform we beat down our banking
Partners on price and what we do is
anyone who onboards to meow to get a
business checking account they can feel
like they're getting a really good
interest rate through the platform and
how exactly are you doing that so
there's only been a few companies that
have ever successfully attracted
business banking deposits as a fintech
facing the startup market and so we had
a lot of social proof with us when we
went to these banking Partners so we
said look guys if you guys give us a
really good rate we'll attract more
customers to use your platform and they
said okay fine let's see what you can do
thankfully we crossed over a billion in
assets on the platform through that so
that's why we had leverage here very
cool now take me back to the beginning I
want to hear all about your founding
story yeah so my co-founder and I we
wanted to start a company our whole
lives thankfully Co came around and it
was a little bit easier to raise funding
we didn't know any ABCs he quit his job
at Facebook he just moved into an
apartment with me we just started coding
non-stop yeah thankfully we got our
first check and investor who believed in
us and one thing led to another we built
a great team and we built a good company
since then thankfully what was it like
you know switching into entrepreneurship
and and taking on that challenge for the
first time it was terrifying yeah I mean
quitting our jobs and not having any
kind of fall back any income any plan
really was was kind of scary it was like
the abyss it's like staring into the
darkness and not knowing what's there
and we just kind of coated our way out
of it and thankfully we could see a
light at the end of the tunnel which was
just our first customer tell me about
how you came up with the name you know
our the investors who passed on us they
said we would never see $1,000 come to
meow we' never see H 100,000 with the
name meow and we're over a billion on
the platform I still get questions about
the name like it's a happy high ceiling
there's dopamine in the name yeah when
you say it just makes you happy and if I
was going for like a single or a double
I would have named it something more
boring right but Bryce and I wanted to
be household name with unlimited
potential and why not just pick the
happiest highest cealing name you could
think of do you love cats is that why I
I'm a dog person that's crazy thing yeah
I I like cats yeah they're
fine what's been the most challenging
part about running
meow challenging part is we're trying to
do everything with the leanest team
possible so when we crossed a billion
and assets on the platform meow
Technologies ink we were 12
people that leads to problems but it
leads to opportunity I mean being so
lean every dollar we save we can
feasibly pass back to our customers but
that means we're constantly underwater
so we have to figure out how to further
automate make this like the most
efficient platform possible that's
that's really the challenge for us I
definitely want to hear about your
fundraising Journey walk me through that
and and where you're at today yeah so
we've raised 30 million to date about
this is our first company and that's
kind of a high number for a first-time
founder with my co-founder Bryce so the
hardest part was getting the first check
cuz when you don't know any VCS every VC
VC is basically looking for social proof
like who else has invested in you you
don't have a good answer for that when
you're starting so you have to find that
one VC who believes in you before anyone
else does and that's super rare that was
a guy named Charlie sers for us and one
thing led to another when people saw
Charlie invested then it's like okay
maybe I can invest too and then kept
going and going and thankfully we raised
raised some money and we can do some big
things with it I think can you talk to
me a bit about your competition who are
they and what sets you apart from them
it's a good question so co-founder told
me look we should never focus on the
competition Jeff bezo says if you obsess
over the customer you don't even need to
think about your competitors at that
point so there are major banks that are
competing with us there are major
fintechs that are competing with us like
ourselves that have you know $4 billion
valuations hundred billion valuations
thousands of people and we're sitting
here at 15 going head-to-head with them
but we just focus on the customers they
kind of guide us to the right path
anyway so we don't we don't we're try
not to think about competitors that much
that makes sense is there any advice you
would give your younger self the day
before you started your company that you
wish you knew now I would say there's a
difference between working hard and
working smart I felt like the longer
hours I worked on something the more it
demonstrated like my knowledge on it
there's ways to work be more efficient
with your time without kind of hurting
yourself over it so I say time
management is a big one something you
have to learn as a Founder
ultimately and what would you like your
legacy to
be honestly if we at the company we just
want to make an impact we just get
excited when people use the product
right and you know there's 30 million
what small businesses in America having
people use meow to access bank accounts
through our platform I mean that just
that would just light me up if every
business was using this I mean that's
just that's a great legacy to
[Music]
have